this is Startalk you ghouls are the most
the weirdest non true thing and you'll
find the website dedicated to that yeah
well if I say in the book if you do a
Google search on age of the earth
you know radioactive dating and you know
some ninth grader might get assigned
that topic right six are the first ten
things that come up prove that
radioactivity is nonsense and the earth
is ten thousand years old really in a
Google you tried it now I'm sorry I'm
trying it right now okay okay so so
therefore having correct information in
the face of misinformation clearly
doesn't work it's a problem it's a
problem well that's not I don't have you
on the show to tell me it's a problem
I've got on the show to tell me how to
solve the solve the solution is changing
the education education so we're not
okay so you have to give up on the holy
stop sorry I I'm actually told what
David said I cannot believe the crap
that is coming up on Google right now
this is unbelievable it would have no
scientific method can prove the age of
the Earth and the universe and that
includes the ones that are listed here
holy crap you're allowed to say that
yeah well so there's a free country
yeah the democratization of information
is good it just comes with this big
baggage and it's with a responsibility
how many different measurable processes
are used to oh my god and it's all and I
got it I don't want to say where the
sources are from because I don't even
want to get into that but this is Tyson
so what you have to advertise them but
this is what you have to do so what you
have to do it seems is everyone else was
a goner you got it then changed the
educational curricula keep their
curiosity first of all so they so they
question everything that do that for
free that preferring they're younger on
the young now but we beat it out of them
right yeah yeah completely
and then concern how to construct
knowledge for themselves so they can use
these tools I call them the little
you know apps to install in your
prefrontal cortex that filter this
information in a way this is G does that
make any sense can I figure out that
makes it I love that if you like this
please remember everything that we do
can be found commercial-free plus
exclusive original content all on
Startalk all-access comm